all right so the magnus game i'm playing
black this is from the title arena
and uh magnus played the center game
which is pretty rare opening these days
but
in bullet magnus plays a lot of
interesting stuff um
this is bullet one plus zero and i think
he he chooses
an opening to play in a tournament and
then it sort of sticks to it
[Music]
um and and here he played the center
game which is d4 e takes d4
and queen takes d4 this is not a
terrible opening it is
it's a it's a pretty venomous line
uh and black has to know what he's doing
it's not very commonly
um it's not very commonly played today
but it is it is something that you can
uncork once in a while
now the danish gambit here is more
popular
the danish game is more popular c3d
takes c3 bishop c4 the danish gambit
rather
and uh this is you know an opening that
i recommend to a lot of beginners very
very
interesting play i won't analyze it
right now thank you d guy 30 but magnus
takes on d4 so
knight c6 of course is black's move and
now point to c4
which is a sideline uh apparently it's
called a hall variation
i think the main line is to drop the
queen back to e3 in order to leave the d
file open for the rook and basically
white very quickly tries to castle long
yeah magnus does it for fun of course he
just tries different lines
so queen c4 i already didn't know i mean
this was unfamiliar to me but i decided
to play
naturally just develop all my pieces
knight f6
knight to c3 and
now bishop v4 just developing actively
as i would normally do
and um
yeah yeah so bishop before pinning the
night magnus goes bishop to d2 unpinning
the knight
castles and castle so very typical
center game kind of action
now my bishop is not developed yet so i
just said well
i didn't play d6 immediately i decided
to start with thank you aldo benko i
decided to
start with rookie 8 and
the point of this is to put pressure on
the e4 pawn
so for example if he goes knight to f3
i can take the knight on c3 and then i
can take on e4
and i'm a full central pawn up and then
i can play d6 so i wanted to force him
into playing f3
and he did he plays f3 to defend the
pawn so this is all very normal
now i play d6 in order to get the bishop
out and magnus goes g4
which is the secondary idea
which is the secondary idea of of
playing f3 you might see this in the
sicilians sometimes white attacks the
king's side with pawns
okay so i go bishop e6 developing my
bishop of tempo and magnus drops the
queen back to e2 so far everything has
been
very normal i mean for the center game
and this is where things heat up i
decided that i'm just going to go all in
this game
my wins against magnus all of them have
occurred in super tactical positions
and i figured that my i don't want to
get into some sort of a drawn out
endgame so i figured i'd just throw all
my pieces at him and if it worked it
worked if it didn't work it doesn't work
and i found a good opportunity to start
doing that here
um there black is a couple of ways to
play this kind of position but there's a
very aggressive move here that i spotted
and the moment i spotted it i played it
i didn't calculate anything
so who can who can spot this move
yeah so the typical move is d5 but it's
even more direct than d5 d5
doesn't really stop g5 and the knight is
attacked and if the knight moves then
you might end up losing your d5 pawn
thank you fr mack for the tier one
but the move is knight d4 yeah and
it may seem like a paper tiger because
white goes queen f2
and waitress attacks the knight like
what was the purpose of this but the
follow up here is
c7 to c5 this not only defends the
knight what else does this move
accomplish
what do we prepare here and this is
where things
really get heated
excuse me thank you
jason appreciate it yeah it opens the
queen the queen is going to come out to
a5
that is going to be big problems for
white because now i have a bunch of
pieces
accumulated on the queen side so magnus
goes
a3 to attack my bishop but obviously in
the spirit of what i had promised myself
these are not rhetorical questions in
the spirit of what i had promised myself
i wasn't just going to meekly retreat
the bishop to a5 because that would
block the queen's pathway to a5
i went queen a5 anyway and it's not hard
to see that taking the bishop is
horrific because i give him this check
it's not mate because he can drop the
knight back
this knight on b1 is absolutely toast
after bishop
a2 then i just take the knight and if
it's not checkmate then i'll massacre
him along these squares
and uh this one i had you know i'd seen
this when i played c5 so i essentially
pre-moved queen a5
but magnus finds a really magnus-like
defensive move
now black is threatening bishop takes a3
which would rip open the king's defenses
and
i still have enough pieces there to give
checkmate so magnus drops his knight
back to b1 that was a very annoying move
uh because what this move accomplishes
is
well it it starts forcing a bunch of
trades which i don't want because i'm
attacking and it protects the a3 pawn
and it leaves black's pieces in the dust
so knight b1 came as a bit of a surprise
to me i spent six seconds on the next
move which is a lot for bullet
but i determined that i have to take his
bishop because now he's threatening to
play a takes before now
now this is a threat because the queen
a1 is no longer a check
so bishop takes d2 queen takes d2 and of
course i shouldn't trade queen so i drop
my queen back to b6
now magnus continues the attack with g5
attacking my knight
i have no choice but to move the knight
back and magnus goes up four and f4 was
the key mistake
this is the decisive mistake after which
i played very very well to win the game
um and f4 is a very natural move but
magnus simply overlooked
my my response i think the correct move
here was probably to go
it's actually not easy to play this with
white he i think he had to move his
queen
i did get second place yes but at this
point i noticed that his king and the
queen as i often advise
on the speedrun are in a forkable
situation right a knight on b3 could
result in a fork
um and and and obviously i can't go
knight b3 immediately he just takes the
knight but you can
improve that tactic you can do something
in order to pave the way for an ip3
and that move is bishop to b3 yes so
bishop b3 is a
super strong move it attacks the pawn on
c2 and it
what's up proffer and if he takes then i
fork the king to the queen
the king and the queen um
and if he pushes the pawn forward then
he gives up the exchange and that's
i don't think anyone's saying that nick
sniper that's you're the only one saying
that
and if he doesn't do anything then i
take the pawn so magnus is an only move
here which is bishop out to d3
he's not going to go gentle into that
goodnight because now
the point is if i take on c2 then he's
going to take back with the bishop and
he protects the
forking square but in this position
i notice that this bishop on d3 is
actually very vulnerable so i play the
move
c4 dislodging this bishop
still if he takes takes on b3 then i
take back
with the knight and this is a fork to
the king of the queen but magnus finds a
really cool move here
now what he notices is that this move c4
has left the knight on d4 undefended
it's only now protected by the queen
but white's got two potential attackers
on that night
and so magnus takes on c4 i missed this
move
and he spent a whopping one second on it
which just shows you
how sharp this guy is and the point is
that after bishop c4 queen takes d4
white finally gets this knight out of
the picture
and white is upon it i have nothing to
show for it
and the issue bishop takes c2 might seem
tempting but still queen takes d4
and um if you take the rope then the
queen takes and
this actually might be decent for black
but it's not
it's not that clear but in this position
i found something really really cool
so when i noticed is that bishop take c4
has the effect of opening the c
file and the c file is a direct line of
fire to white's king
so the move that i naturally started
considering i played this move
immediately
i mean i don't know how it just kind of
occurred to me this idea just sort of
occurred to me
and i decided to roll with it it's rook
a2c8
now this move itself should be pretty
obvious to everybody the point is
this is actually checkmate i'm not just
winning the queen this is literally
checkmate
but here's the amazing part of it magnus
takes the knight on d4 anyway
and now rook takes c4 and um
this attacks the queen and it threatens
checkmate on c2
and um yeah we takes d4
rook takes c4 if he takes my queen this
is just checkmate
it doesn't matter what truck you put on
c8 but
of course magnus doesn't take on b6
and magnus drops his queen back to d3
and so the obvious move here is
to play rope 62 and this of course wins
this wins the queen but it wins the
queen for a rook and a piece look it's
the game is not quite over yet
all right guys there's no need to to
spam leeches
uh you know it's it just it doesn't add
anything to the chat so
you know it's funny one time but there's
no need to just keep repeating it
so this um this wins the queen for the
for the rook in the night um we're just
reviewing a game guys
and um but in this position i spotted
something really really cool
i noticed that the queen protects the
pawn on c2 and i've always said that the
queen is the worst defender
so what can black do here and this is
this is a really cool move yeah queen e3
check of course it's very simple but
it's
it's pretty uh if he takes my queen then
this is once again checkmate it's just a
simple decoy sacrifice queen e3 check
and uh he's absolutely busted here
because
well he he did not he declined to take
he played rook to d2 that's the only
other move
and here i catch my composure it's not
that easy to find
the crushing move but here i simply took
on c2 and he resigned
if he well he has no choice i mean king
d1 just walks into a discovery
his only chances to take but compared to
the previous position i have the move
queen takes c4 check which forks
the king and the rook on h1 and this
wins another rook and this wins the game
on the spot
so that's the key difference but queen
e3 was actually the only move that won
the game immediately
um so this was all yeah
this was all precise according to the
computer from
from the move c5 i played pretty much
the top moves
so it was a it was a moment of
inspiration but once you when i was in
the moment you know you feel the
excitement
um but i i could just sense once this
king was boxed in like that on c1
thanks montana that that that something
was about to go down
yeah so i had a couple of nice games in
the title to arena yeah yeah no i mean i
got lucky with this king and his
configuration of the queen and the king
can i repeat the whole combo i can do
that one more time
so c4 is where it starts i think
no i guess bishop b3 is where it's a
bishop b3 trying to get rid of the pawn
and now c4 to dislodge the bishop so
everything revolves around trying to
make sure that this pawn disappears
but after bishop takes c4 this is really
the most important move of the comedy
without rook ac8
everything would fail um and now the
point is if he takes then i
take back that is what happened that is
the only move queen to d3
trying to at least give up the queen for
a rook and a piece
but no sir queen e3 check distracting
the queen
um he's got to block that he can't take
my queen because of mate now we play
rook takes c2 and he resigned
takes takes takes and the final move is
queen takes c4 which is why he resigned
timothy robert ryan think of the prime
appreciate it
it's forks the queen of the rook so yeah
that
that's basically it um that was my
nicest game of the
tournament i had a couple of good games
i'll find them and
show them later um thank you i
appreciate it everybody
why not queen takes well because if we
take on d3 and take on c2 discover
checks can be overrated sometimes black
is winning of course but it's not as
convincing black can go here for example
yeah this is completely winning too but
that the
my move wins even faster because it wins
just a queen yeah i think two i won 250
bucks for second place
but i you know i don't really play in
these tournaments for money it's just a
lot it's a big honor to play magnus and
nelly brezz and all these people it's
super fun and uh it's just a good way to
spend two hours so
um yeah but that's a good question about
why not taking the queen
is there a difference between rook ac
and roquisia another great question no
there isn't
um i don't think there is but i like
rook acape just to make sure the back
rank is a little safer
i think rookie ec8 is a little awkward
alireza came first
alireza was first elireza beat my beat
me to the ground that tournament at this
tournament he
he had my number he played amazing ellie
reza just played
incredible chess so very well deserved
uh
very well deserved victory by lereza
this was this morning
[Music]
you